[Musique]
leo au fus par 14 ans sinon il ya du
tabac dedans
je me charge est un coquin nantes aura
pas le temps me lancer bah si
moi je faisais pipi ça fait deux heures
qu'on fait là que pour toi alors notre
temps tu te rends tu compte là dedans
[Musique]
vous rendez pas compte en fait on a
transféré nos esprits dans le corps de
quelqu'un d'autre
on hésite la plus grande découverte de
l'immunité et mon anniversaire
c'est pas le moment pour l'anniversaire
vous inquiétez pas on rentre à la maison
c'est ça et surtout et ont l'air normal
et si ce pas ça vous partez ouais c'est
dommage ça pour chercher à nous
on y va pourquoi c'est pas juste c'est
mon anniversaire mais [ __ ] fait
circuler
mais qu'a fait comment tu me parles
bouazizi non arrête avec ton saisie
maintenant et du fils au
sérieux je suis dans le corps de papa
maintenant
calme-toi valentine que silent hill
hervé oui c'est ça j'en suis vieille et
moche et barbu message vocal
fait chier votre truc mais
je te rappelle je t'explique premier
[Musique]
[ __ ] mais dégage latuquois pas
toulousaine